[Musique]
histoire journaliste présentateur
caméraman
il n'est jamais trop tôt pour apprendre
les métiers de l'audiovisuel
c'est en tout cas ce que prouve cet
atelier organisé au musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines à 9 ans basile
est déjà bien décidés caméraman au moins
tu as ta des boutons tu peux appuyer tu
peux filmer sur tout ce qui est bien
c'est que tu peux regarder beaucoup de
choses préparez un journal construire un
reportage et choisir ses intervenants le
tout sur fond de l'exposition
générations écran une émission pour
apprendre aussi l'histoire de la
télévision
son évolution de ses débuts dans les
années 30 à aujourd'hui à l'idée la
speakerine de la tv en noir et blanc n'y
a qu'une seule chaîne n'a pas le choix
c'est la télé a faim c'est l'état qui a
le monopole vraiment sur la télévision
ça c'est quelque chose déjà qui est
beaucoup plus difficile même pour les
adultes 1 pour se projeter en fait dans
le passé donc ça c'est une partie qui
les intéressent souvent et après ce qui
est important c'est de comprendre que
c'est un média en constante évolution
que tout n'a pas eu la télé en même
temps je pensais que tout le monde
allait la voir en même temps à la même
époque
sammarco n'était que mon enfance ça m'a
permis de faire partager de partager que
mes enfants
des choses comme les dessins animés des
émissions cultes dorothée club des
choses comme ça de leur donner un aperçu
en fait de ce que moi j'ai vécu un
plongeon dans le passé mais aussi un
aperçu du futur
prochain atelier le 2 mars d'autres
dates sont à venir pendant les vacances
d'avril aux larmes aux yeux je ne vois
pas bien effectivement justement donc
j'essaie de modèles ac